Хто такі роми?
Існує нація ромів,
а діалектів біля 50-ти.
Буває так, що двоє ромів,
сидячи навпроти, не можуть порозумітися,
використовуючи рідну мову. Тому часто треба перекладати.
Я займаюся шоу-бізнесом, концертною діяльністю.
Я художній керівник циганського шоу-ансамблю "Барон"
Одного разу ми були в Угорщині
на міжнародному фестивалі.
Сидять румунські роми із Болгарії
і намагаються спілкуватися.
Я реготав!
Особисто знаю кілька діалектів
і допомагав їм порозумітися, перекладав.
Усі сміялися!
Ось така ситуація була.
Бачите, ніби один народ
на тлі 40-мільйонного населення України,
це виходить один відсоток становлять роми.
Наше прізвище Огли, я Петро Огли.
Це говорить про те,
що прізвище відноситься до роду тюркських.
Тобто до татарських і азербайджанських.
Навіть наш діалект схожий більше на тюркську,
є багато запозичень.
Можливо, теж частково
ми належимо до кримських татар.
Наприклад, є в Україні серви (етногрупа ромів),
вони навіть вдома спілкуються українською.
Вони дуже давно оселилися в Україні.
Серви - це значить "українські цигани".
Я їм говорю,
що ви краще володієте українською мовою,
аніж самі українці.
Звісно, вони теж використовують свій
ромський діалект - сервицький.
Я вільно з ними спілкуюсь,
адже знаю цей діалект.
Я сюди переїхав у 1984 році
з міста Алмати (Казахстан).
Усі мої діти там народилися.
Там я розпочав свою творчу діяльність,
закінчив Казахський національний університет,
факультет керівника естрадного оркестру.
Протягом усього життя з музикою.
У вільний від навчання час
підробляв у ресторані - грав.
Я - професійний гітарист і вокаліст.
Мене багато хто знає в Україні,
адже ми багато виступаємо на різних подіях.
Тут давно мешкає моя сестра,
і вона запросила нас переїхати.
Батько й мати вирішили,
що ми переїдемо до України.
Тут я розпочав концертну діяльність.
Дякуємо!
Є багато батьків,
які хочуть, щоб їхні діти навчалися.
Але немає фінансової можливості.
Закінчила дитина школу, потрібно вступати до університету,
а коштів на це немає.
У кого є можливість,
то зараз навчаються. Так, я знаю,
на сьогоднішній день
дуже багато дітей навчаються у вузах.
Проте головною проблемою
залишаються фінанси.
Часто 9-10 класів закінчують
і йдуть на свій хліб, не навчаються далі. Інші є - взагалі не вчаться:
коли 2-3 класи дитина походила,
кинула і нічим не займається.
Такі теж є, багато людей.
Особисто мене батько змусив.
Казав: "Учися!".
Якось від дитинства
я був налаштований отримати вищу освіту.
Мені вдалося досягти цієї мети.
Хто хоче, той завжди зробить.
Вічна боротьба,
як було в історії Давида і Голіафа.
Вічна боротьба.
Контролюємо ромських дітей,
щоб ходили до школи.
Це дуже строго! Я особисто це контролюю,
щоб не було таких випадків,
коли 2-3 роки дитина повчилася
і "стала освіченою".
Багато дітей зараз ходять до школи,
хоча є випадки,
коли не хочуть, - силою не змусиш.
Я докладаю максимум зусиль,
аби заохочувати дітей навчатися.
Ось 5 чоловік закінчили
юридичний факультет у Одесі.
Один на відділ прокурора пішов...таких багато є,
котрі мають ступінь професора, кандидата наук...
Всі ми живемо в одній країні.
Ми чим від вас відрізняємось?
Ми що, хліб якийсь особливий їмо? Чи ви?
Ми всі йдемо до магазину купувати і їмо одне й те саме,
п'ємо одну воду або чай.
Чим ми відрізняємося?
Проблеми, які існують сьогодні в Україні,
впливають на багато сфер
суспільного життя.
Ми всі люди,
яка різниця якої національності?
Це не має значення.
Усі ми боримось
із одними й тими ж проблемами.
Українець ти чи ром -
вже не має значення.
Ми зустрілись, побули ми, і ось якось треба вирішувати: чи пристосовуватись, чи терпіти... і вже думай.
Субтитри - Владислав Цовма.